LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
OSCAR ISAAC!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> THANK YOU.
OH, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU!
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M SO EXCITED TO BE HERE.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME HOSTING
"SNL."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
THEY ACTUALLY ASKED ME TO HOST
BACK IN 2015 BUT I SAID "NO, I'M
NOT READY.
I WANT TO WAIT UNTIL AFTER THE
PANDEMIC."
AND THEY WERE LIKE, "WHAT
PANDEMIC?"
[ LAUGHTER ]
MY NAME IS OSCAR ISAAC, BUT MY
FULL NAME IS
OSCAR ISAAC HERNANDEZ ESTRADA.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
I SAID TO HOLLYWOOD -- I SAID TO
THEM, "YOU CAN PICK TWO OF THESE
NAMES."
GUESS WHAT THEY WENT WITH.
THE WHITE ONES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M HALF GUATEMALAN, HALF CUBAN.
OR AS CASTING DIRECTORS CALL
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT, "ETHNICALLY AMBIGUOUS."
OR AS CASTING DIRECTORS CALL
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT, "ETHNICALLY AMBIGUOUS."
ACCORDING TO THEM, I CAN PLAY
[ LAUGHTER ]
ANYTHING FROM A PHARAOH TO
ACCORDING TO THEM, I CAN PLAY
TIMOTHEE CHALAMET'S DADDY.
ANYTHING FROM A PHARAOH TO
YOU KNOW THAT JOKE, A PRIEST, A
TIMOTHEE CHALAMET'S DADDY.
RABBI, AND A MINISTER WALK INTO
YOU KNOW THAT JOKE, A PRIEST, A
A BAR?
RABBI, AND A MINISTER WALK INTO
YEAH, I COULD PLAY ANYONE IN
A BAR?
THAT JOKE.
YEAH, I COULD PLAY ANYONE IN
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT JOKE.
BUT I AM EXCITED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M JOINING THE MARVEL UNIVERSE
BUT I AM EXCITED.
WITH "MOON KNIGHT."
I'M JOINING THE MARVEL UNIVERSE
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WITH "MOON KNIGHT."
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF A FULL
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
CIRCLE MOMENT SINCE THE FIRST
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF A FULL
MOVIE I WAS EVER IN WAS CALLED
CIRCLE MOMENT SINCE THE FIRST
"THE AVENGER."
MOVIE I WAS EVER IN WAS CALLED
NOT "THE AVENGERS," WHICH WAS A
"THE AVENGER."
MASSIVE BLOCKBUSTER.
NOT "THE AVENGERS," WHICH WAS A
NO, THIS WAS "THE AVENGER,"
MASSIVE BLOCKBUSTER.
WHICH IS A MOVIE THAT I WROTE,
NO, THIS WAS "THE AVENGER,"
DIRECTED, AND STARRED IN WHEN I
WHICH IS A MOVIE THAT I WROTE,
WAS 10 YEARS OLD.
DIRECTED, AND STARRED IN WHEN I
IT WAS SHOT ON LOCATION IN MY
WAS 10 YEARS OLD.
BUDDY BRUCE FERGUSON'S BACK YARD
IT WAS SHOT ON LOCATION IN MY
IN OUR HOMETOWN OF MIAMI,
BUDDY BRUCE FERGUSON'S BACK YARD
FLORIDA.
IN OUR HOMETOWN OF MIAMI,
I PLAY A NINJA ASSASSIN TRAINING
FLORIDA.
TO FIGHT HIS NEMESIS.
I PLAY A NINJA ASSASSIN TRAINING
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A CLIP.
TO FIGHT HIS NEMESIS.
THIS IS REAL, CHECK THIS OUT.
>> OKAY, THERE'S THE OPENING
TITLE.
AND THERE I AM.
KIND OF LOSING MY BALANCE A
LITTLE BIT.
PERFECT EDITING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND HERE COMES MY BIG STUNT.
I TRAINED TWO MONTHS FOR THIS.
YAH!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
I MEAN, ARGUABLY BETTER THAN THE
REAL "AVENGERS."
AND I MADE IT FOR HALF THE
BUDGET, ONLY $110 MILLION.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT I TOOK IT REALLY SERIOUSLY.
MAYBE A LITTLE TOO SERIOUSLY.
LIKE IN THIS SCENE.
OKAY, THERE I AM ACTING MY HEART
OUT.
AND THERE'S MY FRIEND'S DAD
CLEANING THE POOL.
SHOUT-OUT TO MR. FERGUSON, AND
SHOUT-OUT TO MY BUDDY, BRUCE.
HE'S AT HOME WATCHING AND HE HAD
NO IDEA OUR OLD MOVIE WAS GOING
TO BE ON "SNL."
I ACTUALLY HAD TO SIGN A
LICENSING AGREEMENT TO SHOW IT.
THAT'S TRUE.
NBC UNIVERSAL NOW OWNS "THE
AVENGER."
COMING THIS FALL TO PEACOCK!
[ APPLAUSE ]
I'VE GOT ONE MORE CLIP.
THIS IS A SCENE I DID WITH
MYSELF WHERE I PLAY BOTH PARTS.
OKAY?
HERE WE GO.
THAT'S ME.
I'M MY OWN HENCHMAN.
UH-OH.
NOW WATCH WHAT I DO WITH THE
SWORD.
TOTAL COMMITMENT FROM THE START.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOW, YOU MIGHT BE ASKING, OSCAR,
WHY DID YOU USE YOUR MONOLOGUE
TO SHOW US THESE OLD HOME
VIDEOS?
AND THE REASON IS IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ENCOURAGE KIDS TO BE WEIRDOS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
BECAUSE EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE
ONE OF THOSE WEIRDOS GROWS UP TO
HOST "SNL."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE'VE GOT A GREAT SHOW FOR YOU
TONIGHT.
CHARLI XCX IS HERE.
SO STICK AROUND.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]